well you know I wasn't a big fan of the
first Shrek film but I absolutely adored
the second one so I didn't really know
what to expect with the third one would
they up the ante or take a giant step
backwards a giant step backwards right
down to the villain being one that we
already had Prince Charming yeah that's
right half of the evil duo from the last
movie is kind of like the Riddler and
two-face being the criminals in one
movie in the next one it's just two-face
but that's not the only reason to not
like the movie the dialogue is clumsy
the characters awkward the pacing pretty
inconsistent and the jokes not all that
funny okay so what's going on in this
film actually what isn't going on
Fiona's father dies in a surprisingly
kind of distasteful death scene which
means now Shrek has to be king Blood
Shrek doesn't want to be king so he sets
off to find the real owner of the throne
Arthur a whiny little awkward teen
played by Justin Timberlake well and it
does get a laugh here and there they go
to the help of Merlin played by Eric
Idle who also gets a lot of really good
laughs actually but while that's going
on they figure out that Prince Charming
has taken over far far away and is
holding the Queen and the princesses
hostage so Shrek has to make it back and
save the day
while fiona has to break out with her
ladies to take back the kingdom all
while also tying in a story that fiona
is pregnant and shrek is nervous about
being a father she can tell from the
plot that's a lot going on but they
could still potentially work as long as
to keep the characters in focus and
throwing a lot of good humour which as I
said before they really don't I remember
when I saw this with an audience most of
the people were just sort of sitting
there in silence I mean there was a
laugh here there and one or two good
lines but kind of like the first one the
plot just sort of moves and meanders
without too many jokes even really being
told there's not really that many new
characters I remember Arthur was kind of
enjoyable and Merlin was pretty funny
and the gimmick of the princess is going
from damsels in distress to fighters is
funny or a bit but quickly where's that
joke out and yeah that's about it when I
think of Shrek 2 and I think of all the
great characters we got from that Puss
in Boots the fairy godmother Prince
Charming the king and queen the
disgruntled elves
I worked for the godmother I remember so
much from that film and yet remember so
little from this one and I think what
makes it even worse than something like
the first Shrek film is that well I'm
not fan of the first Frek film at Lisa
had a good set of for a story and it did
have a decent heart to it as well as a
good moral this one just seems much more
choppy with some jokes coming in at
inappropriate moments and others where
there should be funny jokes the dramatic
moments rarely pay off I think for me
it's probably the least of the series I
don't know a ton of people that like it
I mean I'm sure it has a few fans out
there but I've never met anyone that
said oh yeah Shrek the third that's my
favorite it's a shame that after a
sequel as good as Shrek 2 they couldn't
have a follow-up that was just as good
especially with so much stuff going on
would this be the end of anything good
coming out of the Shrek franchise
well I'll fill you in when I get around
to Shrek but for this one I say you can
definitely skip
you